un respiro para la amazonía el mes de
abril supuso una importante reducción en
la pérdida de cobertura vegetal según
los datos del instituto brasileño de
estudios espaciales la deforestación en
abril de este año fue de 329 kilómetros
cuadrados frente a los 1026 de abril de
2022 esto se traduce en una caída de
casi un
68%, además en los cuatro primeros meses
del presente año la deforestación cayó
un 40% respecto al mismo periodo del
estos datos llegan en medio del comienzo
del mandato del presidente Luis Ignacio
violada Silva quien asumió en enero y
tiene como objetivo acabar con la
deforestación para 2030 Brasil señala
que estas cifras pueden tener alguna
relación con ciertas políticas de Lula
como la reestructuración de los órganos
de defensa ambiental Gobierno Federal el
Gobierno Federal reestructuró todo el
área ambiental tenemos el regreso de las
inspecciones
y las operaciones de Mando y control en
la selva se relanzaron recientemente
las políticas de Lula Son drásticamente
opuestas a las de su antecesor Yahir
bolsonaro quien redujo el presupuesto y
el personal en agencias ambientales
claves Bajo su mandato entre 2019 y 2022
la deforestación en la amazonia aumentó
un 60% ahora los expertos aseguran que
las cifras de 2023 No son suficientes
para hablar de una tendencia y habrá que
esperar al periodo entre julio y
septiembre cuando se registra el pico
anual de deforestación